Democrats running for president will
face off for the fifth time tonight 10
of the president's potential rivals for
2020 have made the cut for tonight's
debate so recent polling shows four of
them nearly tied at the top with mayor
Pete Buda judged the latest candidate to
take a surge at ok fees in Atlanta a big
of a roll with these impeachment
hearings play in tonight's debate by the
way it tired of berry studios that okay
that's right we're headed to Tyler Perry
studios later tonight impeachment not
expect it to be a big factor because the
candidates running to replace the
president don't often talk about it and
that's partly because neither do the
voters you go to campaign events and
they usually ask questions about the
issues health care the economy climate
change civil rights foreign policy this
will be the first debate since the
campaign essentially became a four
person race in early states depending on
the poll mayor Buda judge is either out
in front or tied with former Vice
President Joe Biden and Senators
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders only
ten candidates will appear on stage
tonight at Tyler Perry studios down from
12 earlier last month for the next
debate the number of participants will
likely continue dropping as they
struggle to meet fundraising and polling
requirements as the primaries approach
not appearing tonight former
Massachusetts governor Deval Patrick
would just jumped into the race last
week and former New York Mayor Mike
Bloomberg who's still hanging out there
yet to announce whether he's jumping
energy Anthony Willie or won't he add
thank you very much